emily is in Indiana Dave I haven't heard
you mention the Li RP the life insurance
retirement policy in terms of retirement
investing it seems like a Roth IRA but
to an insurance company with life
insurance included I'm debt free and
I've been super approved oh wow it's
always good to get super approved as
opposed just approved for a a and hello
and health a li RP through a company
investing in an Li RP sounds like a good
idea why would you not recommend
investing in it because it sucks that's
why it's a horrible rate of return
anytime you get involved with a cash
value life insurance policy you are
going to get horrible terms and high
expenses and so there's just no
exceptions to that some are slightly
better than others but one sucks and the
others just double sucks and you just
don't there's no point in doing this
listen you're much better off to do your
investing in good investments there are
no good life insurance investment
products
there's none there's none that can keep
up with decent growth stock mutual funds
invested in your 401 K in your Roth IRA
we've just finished surveying ten
thousand one hundred and sixty two
millionaires asking them how they got
there you know how many of them got to
be millionaires
because they bought cash value life
insurance of the ten thousand that we
interviewed you know how many 0 out of
over 10,000 millionaires not one said
they used a cash value life insurance
product to become one
not one said I did all my investing in
cash value in Li RPS in indexed
universal life policies in universal
policies in variable life policies not
one out of 10,000 said they built their
wealth using life insurance as an
investment product not even one
I mean my god you would think that a
blind hog could find an acre never so
often that at least one out of 10,000
could become millionaires but these
products suck so bad that they suck the
very bone marrow out of your cash flow
and they put it down a rat hole you're
flushing it down the toilet and it
virtually guarantees you're not gonna
build wealth so when you're arrogant
got their glasses down on the tip of his
nose rolling his eyes about Dave Ramsey
insurance agent says well all the
wealthiest value life insurance let me
just tell you I have done our company is
just doing with Chris Hogan the largest
study of millionaires in North America
ever done and not one of them not even
at least I mean there were more people
that became wealthy using CDs making
nothing on their money than they did
using insurance as an investment product
they all say I mean like 80 89 91 % they
say I used mutual funds from my Roth
IRAs and my 401ks and I put money in
there and I paid off my house and ten
point two years and the this is almost
every one of them so that the deal is
this
not one have I made myself clear not
even one of these millionaires that
we've interviewed I have I can't I think
of anyone I've talked to in 30 years of
doing this and said Dave you know I made
my money the thing that caused me to
become wealthy was I invested in life
insurance I've never heard that not once
now I will admit to a bias on that
because I tell people it's stupid for 30
years I've told people it's stupid so
I'm not likely to run into somebody that
goes hey I'm stupid so if they know it's
me now the survey the research we did
did not know it was me doing the
research so they were not biased in
their answers but you know if I'm
talking to somebody here on the air
they're not gonna likely to call up and
go you know I got rich using whole life
life insurance from Northwestern Mutual
I've never heard that
I mean buying life and buying a whole
life life insurance from Northwestern
Mutual it's kind of like buying $100,000
boat it's a good way to turn a hundred
thousand dollars into ten thousand you
know it's it's a good way to take a
billionaire and make them into a
millionaire you know it's just so let's
just not be unclear about this there's
no data anywhere except hypothetical
examples buy your whole life agent buy
your cash value life insurance agent
that says this is a good idea it's just
not a good idea folk hope I wasn't
unclear